radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene is
now claiming that her television turns
itself on to spy on her did this not
really happen and is she lying that's a
possibility more likely than the one she
is outlining did she sit on the remote
that is a possibility is it a smart TV
with some kind of learning function that
maybe has figured out a schedule where
it believes Marjorie Taylor green wants
to be watching TV sure is it her
boyfriend Brian Glenn the guy from right
side broadcasting who hooked up his
laptop to the TV and uh it turned on and
went right to the last input that was
selected like any single one of these
explanations would make more sense so
Marjorie Taylor green insisting she's
not on any medications but maybe she
should be that would be something to
look at